[Música]
bienvenidos a medio ambiente en france
24 como medida de prevención por la
situación de la pandemia de kobe 19 en
bogotá donde estaba la sede de france 24
en español el programa de esta semana
llega de nuevo producido desde casa el
25 de julio un buque de carga japonés se
encayó en aguas poco profundas de isla
mauricio en el océano índico el barco
que transportaba unas 4000 toneladas de
combustible fue quebrándose poco a poco
al tiempo que cientos de miles de kilos
de petróleo se escapaban contaminando
las turquesas aguas insulares en total
se calcula que unas mil toneladas se han
derramado en una área que afecta a unos
15 kilómetros de costa poco más de un
mes después del accidente las labores de
limpieza continúan y poco a poco se van
evaluando los daños ambientales un
equipo de expertos japoneses viajó a la
isla para ayudar en las labores del
estudio del impacto en manglares y
arrecifes de corales de la zona
inspeccionamos 12 puntos del área desde
el arrecife hasta la zona donde se
encalló el barco no hemos visto ningún
coral que haya muerto directamente por
el derrame de petróleo tampoco vimos
lugares donde se haya acumulado aceite
en los corales o en el fondo marino sin
embargo cuanto más se acerca uno a la
zona del accidente más turbia hasta el
agua creemos que esto es porque el barco
ha sido zarandeado por las olas y ha
destruido corales
si la situación continúa durante mucho
más tiempo los corales sufrirán más
presión y seguramente se mueran
y ahí donde la contaminación es severa
las raíces por donde respiran los
manglares puede que estén cubiertas de
petróleo y eso hará que se asfixian y
mueran o que mueran por el veneno
liberado por la contaminación del
derrame
aunque por ahora no se ha registrado
ninguna muerte en los manglares los
equipos no lo descartan ya que
este tipo de derrames suele durar meses
o años en mostrar su verdad el impacto
es el impacto real y a largo plazo aún
tiene que ser determinado es un siglo
veis
11 freeze cuál será el impacto futuro en
los arrecifes de coral en el pasto
marino en las poblaciones de peces en
las especies de pájaros endémicas o en
los inusuales reptiles que hemos tratado
de conservar durante los últimos 40 años
o días la muerte en los últimos días de
al menos 40 delfines en la zona afectada
por el derrame es otro de los posibles
impactos pero aún se están esperando los
resultados de la autopsia de los
animales los delfines habían aparecido
ya muertos en las orillas de la isla y
se teme que el número de cetáceos
fallecidos sea mucho mayor hasta el
momento de la grabación de este programa
las únicas dos autopsias que se habían
realizado no mostraban restos de
combustible en los delfines
solo varias contusiones y heridas
superficiales estas autopsias fueron
realizadas por una agencia gubernamental
y algunas ongs locales estaban pidiendo
que los resultados de estas sean
publicados en su totalidad para evitar
que parte de la información sea
censurada además greenpeace exigió que
se investiguen las causas de estas
muertes y si están relacionadas con el
accidente del carguero japonés dejamos
la paradisíaca isla mauricio y vamos
hasta europa cuando la catedral de
notre-dame de parís se incendió el 15 de
abril del año pasado la aguja y el
tejado del edificio desaparecieron y con
ellos las 460 toneladas de plomo que lo
recubrían un material altamente tóxico y
que puede derivar en problemas
neurológicos y 'sin gestado o respirado
las llamas hicieron que parte del metal
se esparciera con el humo y el viento
por las zonas aledañas a la catedral los
estudios que hizo el gobierno francés
tras el accidente mostraban que la
concentración de partículas de plomo en
el aire a una distancia de 50 kilómetros
en la dirección
el viento el día del incendio era 20
veces superior a lo habitual un reciente
informe publicado en el portal
científico
health que analizó 100 muestras de
tierras recolectadas entre 9 y 10 meses
después del incendio en diversos lugares
situados en un radio de un kilómetro
desde notre damme concluye que la zona
directamente la dirección del viento el
día del incendio muestra niveles de
plomo seis veces mayores al depositado
en las áreas más allá de los mil metros
aseguran que estos resultados reflejan
una exposición mucho mayor de la que
publicaron las autoridades francesas en
las semanas y meses posteriores al
incendio sin embargo el estudio asegura
que es difícil confirmar la magnitud del
impacto en la población en esa área ya
que las autoridades no tomaron
suficientes muestras de sangre ni
tampoco del polvo o de la tierra que
rodeaban a la catedral en los días que
siguieron al incendio la oms se deja
claro que no existen niveles seguros de
exposición al plomo y que incluso
niveles bajísimos pueden afectarles
el cerebro y por ende desencadenar un
coeficiente intelectual reducido en
niños en adultos el plomo puede afectar
el funcionamiento de los riñones y eleva
también el riesgo de sufrir hipertensión
los autores del estudio recomiendan que
los países tengan a un equipo de
investigación ambiental listo para
actuar inmediatamente después de
desastres de este tipo que incluyan
materiales con potenciales efectos
nocivos o tóxicos para la salud pública
algo que por ejemplo habría sido de
mucha utilidad tras la explosión que se
dio en beirut capital de líbano el
pasado 4 de agosto en la que casi tres
mil toneladas de nitrato de amonio un
químico utilizado sobre todo en
agricultura destruyera parte de la
ciudad y acabará con la vida de al menos
180 personas es todo por esta semana
recuerden que pueden volver a ver todos
los programas de medioambiente en
nuestro sitio web france24 puntocom
[Música]